scotland forever
fu questo il grido di battaglia dei
soldati scozzesi lanciandosi al galoppo
verso le linee francesi durante la
battaglia di waterloo nel 1815 ed è il
titolo di questo di questo quadro che fu
dipinto da lady butler circa 70 anni
dopo nel 1881 le di butler come donna
non ebbe mai modo di partecipare ad una
battaglia quindi dovete studiare dovette
documentare se dovete fare ricerca
perché doveva poter rappresentare le
divise dei soldati che corrisponde
essere a quelle dell'epoca
dovete studiare l'anatomia degli animali
dei dei cavalli in modo da poterli
rappresentare questa visuale molto
particolare da tal davanti molto
originale grazie al mio lavoro sono ho
avuto la possibilità di rendere omaggio
a questa immagine probabilmente la più
particolare è celebrata di quella di
quell evento e che tanto mi ha
emozionato sin da quando ero ragazzino
come si diceva sono un paio illustratore
ossia un un illustratore di quelli che
si occupano di paleontologia cioè
cercano attraverso lo studio dei dei
fossili di rappresentare il mondo della
preistoria
come ogni artista il l'illustratore
paleontologico ha sempre un po la testa
tra le nuvole nuvole jurassic dehoniane
nel mio caso semi mi piace la natura ne
sono affascinato mi stimola mi mi dà
tanti spunti per realizzare le immagini
che che vedrete inevitabilmente ogni
volta che a me capita di osservare
qualche cosa innaturale tendono
inevitabilmente a trasformarlo in
qualche cosa di preistorico quando io
cammino su un bel prato rasato mi trovo
davanti una quercia ecco immediatamente
tendo a trasformarla in una specie di
albero gigantesco dalle dalle forme
particolari dall'aspetto inusuale alieno
il prato ovviamente diventa una una
distesa acquitrinosa ricca di alberi
caduti
vegetazione rigogliosa i cani che stanno
correndo davanti a me possono
tranquillamente essere dei a dei piccoli
carnivori che si stanno inseguendo che
si stanno contendendo la preda oppure
sopra di me passano i lunghi colli dei
sauropodi che brucano a dieci metri da
terra e dietro il cespuglio che si è
mosso poco fa secondo me c'è sicuramente
qualche grosso animale che sicuramente
può saltare fuori un carnivoro
aggressivo il fatto è che nella mia
testa io continuo a cercare di risolvere
il problema che riguarda l'illustrazione
che sto cercando di realizzare in questi
giorni ho studiato molto bene il
soggetto protagonista del quale
ovviamente non ricordo assolutamente il
nome e che con fondo con un altro che ha
anche lui un nome assolutamente
impronunciabile ecco come lo sono
studiato bene anatomicamente però non mi
piace la postura che gli ho dato e per
rappresentare meglio la l'immagine è
meglio sarebbe meglio che io l'ho
inquadrarsi dall'alto in modo tale da
avere una visione precisa e completa di
tutto il paesaggio e dovrò però spostare
lallo sauro tutto su un lato in modo da
rendere più equilibrata all'immagine e
poter avere una visuale completa dello
scenario
il fatto è che io devo avere a che fare
con i paleontologi i paleontologi i
geologi sono i miei compagni di viaggio
sono coloro che mi supervisionano
quelli che mi danno tutte le
informazioni e le indicazioni che mi
permettono di realizzare l'illustrazione
arrivando a curare i minimi dettagli
anatomici
contemporaneamente però sono anche
coloro che tendono a imbrigliargli a
incanalarsi in una in uno strettissimo
corridoio artistico che serve ad evitare
che il sottoscritto preso dallo slancio
e dal desiderio di rendere sempre più
emozionante e più particolare
l'inquadratura rischi di esagerare e
metal e i soggetti in posizioni tali per
cui risulterebbero poi anatomicamente
impossibili è una specie di csi in
chiave paleontologica il io tutti gli
elementi che mi servono per fare la mia
ricerca ho tutti gli indizi o gli
schizzi e disegni fatti da chi mi ha
preceduto le indicazioni che mi vengono
date da paleontologi geologi quali nella
loro testa hanno chiarissimo come era il
mondo preistorico perché lo studiano il
problema loro e quello di renderlo
visibile e quindi il mio compito è
proprio quello di cercare di scattare
una sorta di istantanea del passato
profondo un lavoro in continua
evoluzione
può capitare che il l'animale che tu hai
con tanta attenzione studiato le monto
sauro cui ha curato ogni minimo
dettaglio
persino la pelle di cui si conoscono le
impronte
ecco salti fuori proprio il giorno prima
che tu stai per consegnare il tuo lavoro
succede che esce uno uno studio che
mette in luce un dettaglio anatomico
veramente insignificante che è una
cresta carnosa proprio in mezzo alla
fronte del nostro soggetto quindi sarà
mia premura quella di cercare di
aggiornare questo animale alla velocità
della luce
stessa cosa può succedere per esempio
per un animale come può essere il
tirannosauro tirannosauri sono tra gli
animali preistorici tra i più conosciuti
in assoluto nel campo della
paleontologia
ecco da qualche tempo i paleontologi
sono
praticamente convinti che i tirannosauri
fossero coperti da una sorta di
piumaggio primitivo che si chiama si
chiamano porto piume quindi una specie
di soffice piumino il che ovviamente
nella mia testa si è presentato subito
come una specie di gigantesco pulcino
mannaro e quindi ho dovuto trasformare
quella vecchia illustrazione di cui
andavano particolarmente fiero in
qualche cosa che fosse anatomicamente
sistemato perché ovviamente c'erano
qualche essendo una cosa vecchia di
qualche anno fa
forse anatomicamente sistemato ma anche
ricoperto di questo piumaggio e cosa
succede quando ci si trova di fronte a
questo tipo di problematiche
la tecnologia ovviamente diventa il
mezzo fondamentale perché si possano
risolvere
e questo il motivo per cui i
paleontologi utilizzano i laser scanner
per avere delle immagini tridimensionali
dei reperti oppure li passano nel fanno
delle tac in modo da poter osservare
l'interno della del nostro fossile senza
doverlo rompere o tagliare gli
illustratori utilizzano photoshop con le
caratteristiche con i caratteristici
livelli sovrapposti mentre le maquette
cioè quei modellini fatti in plastilina
vengono sostituiti dagli dagli scultori
da delle
sculture fatte in pole i nuovi programmi
di modellazione digitale tridimensionale
quindi modellazione 3d è un lavoro
estremamente complesso minuzioso che
deve richiedere tanta pazienza e
dedizione per cui non è
magaro che dopo tanto lavorare su sulla
texture di un animale il sottoscritto
vada a dormire chiuda gli occhi e
continui a vedere squame comines panette
punte artigli seghettature tutto questo
genere di cose però una volta raggiunto
il proprio scopo cioè aver finalmente
realizzato il modello finale si aprono
degli scenari che possono dare spunto a
delle iniziative che non sono
propriamente scientifiche che però danno
anche grande soddisfazione e
divertimento a chi tanto tempo ha
passato su questi su questi soggetti
i paleontologi hanno a disposizione dei
del materiale straordinario materiale
assolutamente incredibile come
è il piccolo giro cioè il cpa unix
samniticus quel piccolo dinosauro che è
stato trovato vicino a pietraroja è che
un cucciolo lo sappiamo perché le
proporzioni del corpo ce lo dicono la
testa molto grande rispetto anzi gli
occhi molto grandi rispetto alla testa
c'è addirittura la fontanella aperta
proprio come i bambini
sappiamo che che cosa ha mangiato perché
la fossilizzazione talmente incredibile
che si vedono persino gli organi interni
e un caso unico al mondo e all'interno
di questi di questi organi state trovate
delle zampine che corrispondono a quelle
di una piccola lucertola sappiamo dove
viveva in un ambiente simile a quello
delle odierne bahamas o ce lo dicono i
sedimenti non sappiamo come e morto e
questo rimane un mistero ma è attraverso
la rappresentazione artistica che noi
possiamo continuare a sognare immaginare
qualche cosa che alla fine resterà
ignoto grazie